[Music]
gas prices
through the roof american energy
production way way down
these things seem to be related
first year of biden in office these
things seem to be related i want to
blame joe biden for this and yet
the left the democrats they tell us it's
not biden's fault these are older
problems this is ridiculous he inherited
the stop you just don't understand
energy you just don't understand the
economy michael okay i'm gonna bring on
someone who does understand energy and
the economy that would be daniel turner
the founder and executive director of
power the future which is a national
nonprofit that advocates for american
energy jobs daniel thank you for coming
on
that's a pleasure to be on with you
thanks for having me before we get into
any substance on energy on fossil fuels
on nuclear perhaps on climate change i
want to focus on a more important
question can i
rightly blame joe biden for the energy
mess right now
yes and we can talk about why
very clear-cut case absolutely okay so
so how is it because what what the
democrats will tell you is
look you're you're going to blame him
for keystone the keystone pipeline the
keystone pipeline wasn't even pumping
energy it wasn't it wasn't even really
operating you're going to blame uh biden
for gas prices going up well biden
doesn't control the cost of oil around
the world you're going to blame biden
for this that and the other thing well
look we have a supply chain crisis we
have a covid lockdown we have this we
have that it isn't the fault of democrat
policies you say
bs
yeah total bs and the reason why is
because energy uh it is a global
commodity and it is uh
on the global stage but energy
production in america has taken a huge
hit we are producing around three
million
fewer barrels of oil per day than we
were just 15 months ago and the reason
why we're producing so much fewer oil is
because of biden energy and
environmental policies so for example
you take someone like deb holland the
secretary of the interior she has
stopped fracking on federal land she has
banned uh and stopped federal uh oil and
gas leases on federal land just the
other day they stopped leasing in the
gulf of mexico so we're cutting into the
supply and as the supply dwindles and we
are dwindling and the demand does not
match that dwindling supply supply well
then clearly prices will go up so the
way to reverse this
is to produce more oil and gas and and
proof of the fact that biden knows this
is that he's asking opec to produce more
oil he knows there's a supply problem
but why can't it be an american supply
solution well i guess the democrats
answer is that producing oil and gas is
bad for the environment it's going to
kill us all within 10 years that's what
and i'm not even exaggerating their
point they actually say
it's going to be all over within 10
years and as so it that would be really
bad and immoral for us to go into our
and and it would be
it would it wouldn't be beautiful it
would be ugly you know we've got all
these beautiful nature preserved so we
don't want to have oil rigs and things
there we don't want oil spills and the
poor little baby seals and so they say
that we just don't want to do it but i
guess the point that you're raising is
why is it any any better if the saudis
are producing it than if we're producing
it here yeah well if it is a global
problem if climate change is a global
issue then where it's produced doesn't
matter so the fact that china has more
emissions than america and europe
combined and china is exempt from
everything like the paris climate accord
xi jinping did not go to that climate
summit last year in glasgow we just
ignore that so then we're acknowledging
it's not really a global problem it's
about something larger and to go back to
your first point this belief that it's a
binary choice we either have a pristine
environment or we have a pollution in
america it's not a choice we have both
we are one of the cleanest countries in
the world and the largest fossil fuel
user and it's the quality of life that
fossil fuels has enabled us that makes
us the envy of the world and and so the
activists the aocs of the world say well
we're going to die of climate change you
know who did die just about a year ago
almost 250 texans died when the wind
turbines froze during their storm
there's another storm right now as we're
talking barreling down on texas and our
philosophy is let's hope the wind
turbines don't freeze so of those 250
people who died
where's their monument right where are
their protesters and they're they died
because liberal politicians have forced
green energy on us in in
in separating it from reliable fossil
fuels we're going to get more of that
under joe biden and i just want to know
how many more people are going to die
before we realize this is all a racket
that's a really good point real people
are dying today because of policies
designed to save hypothetical people in
a decade that doesn't seem like the
right sort of trade-off so okay you
you've convinced me
to uh follow the my priors and the
beliefs that i already wanted to believe
that biden and democrats are at fault
here so what what is the answer on the
substance of energy
let's say there are
three options there's the
leftist
stop coal stop fossil fuels stop
producing stop consuming and just go die
in a cold cold room so that the sun
monster doesn't get us i think i'm only
slightly caricaturing their position
then there's the drill baby drill
position where you just just keep
getting those fossil fuels out of the
ground and then some people have
suggested a third position maybe we move
off of fossil fuels and we move into say
nuclear energy or some other kind of
energy that for some reason the
environmentalists don't seem to like
either but which is efficient and clean
which of those three or maybe a fourth
option do you think is america's energy
future
well i'm a fossil fuel advocate so i'm
going to choose b if those are my
options but just look at the year 2019
as an example in 2019 before the covid
pandemic began we produced more oil and
gas than ever before we employed more
oil and gas workers we brought in more
oil and gas revenue to the federal
treasury we had it at the lowest average
price point than we've had in decades we
didn't have a a four and five dollar
gallon of gas in 2019 gas was less than
two dollars a gallon at the pump and we
lowered emissions more than any other
country in the world and those things
should not all jive together told by the
environmental left you can produce more
oil and gas and have lower emissions and
the reason why 2019 is such a banner
year
we didn't discover a new oil and gas
field we didn't have a new technology
invented we just let the free markets do
what it does best and when free people
are enabled
to work in a free market they produce
more of a good at a lower price point
for the greatest number of people in the
most efficient way it was an amazing
year and and we've watched it all
crumble yes because of covid but also
because of joe biden and we could go
back to it um we just don't have this
administration doesn't have the
political courage and the will to do so
i i really like this point you can do
both it's it's not a binary you actually
can produce more energy you can help
more americans and you can reduce
emissions but then does that does that
not imply
that that we should reduce emissions
that it's a good thing to because i'm
i'm a little
ambivalent on the question i don't i
don't know i do i do not believe the
doomsday
prophecies of climate change killing us
all in a decade i don't really believe
the genius experts who can predict with
absolute certainty what the weather is
going to be like in belize in 2057.
and so i but but i'm i'm not also
totally on the other side where i think
carbon emissions we can just spew
whatever we want into the atmosphere and
that will have no effect on anything i
just i simply don't know so what what do
you think is the reasonable conservative
position here should we
attempt to reduce carbon emissions
albeit in a way that is uh more
conducive to continuing to use fossil
fuels yeah i mean carbon emissions is
the metric du jour and whether or not
it's a good one i i can't answer that
should we be as environmentally
conscious as possible absolutely and we
are in america and anyone who doesn't
think we are has never been to an oil
and gas site they've never been in a
coal mine or been to a coal plant and
this is where i spend the bulk of my
time um but i agree with you this
admissions metric is thrown at us by
groups like uh the united nations and
like the eu
and again and if emissions but here's
the joke about it if emissions is your
big motivating factor look at countries
like germany their emissions are going
through the roof as they go greener
their emissions continue to go up look
at countries like china and russia and
brazil and india which just scoff at
emissions because they're leaders for
good or for ill and some of those
leaders are bad actors for good or for
ill those leaders are putting the
economy of their countries ahead of
everything ahead of greta thunder ahead
of the united nations ahead of
everything they're not going to
compromise their electric grid their
manufacturing sector for some globalist
standard and god i wish america would
have the same courage of defending its
economy and its workers and its and its
productivity and prosperity and and just
shun all these globalist actors that are
trying to do us harm sure yeah that the
idea that
regardless of what you think about the
carbon emissions
even if you do think it's the biggest
deal in the world the countries who are
allegedly prioritizing this aren't doing
much at all i remember there was a
report that came out i think the first
or second year of the trump
administration after the environmental
left was furious that we pulled out of
the sacred paris climate accord and it
turned out we had upheld our end of the
bargain that we pulled out of much
better than the signatories who actually
remained in the paris climate accord so
that's a great way to kind of break out
of this what might be a false binary
here but then so i know that you're a
fossil fuels advocate but what would
your take be on something like for
instance nuclear power for many years
it's been considered a great alternative
energy highly more efficient than any
other kind of energy we've got and yet
the environmental left which you would
think would love nuclear energy
absolutely hates it and they'd much
rather have the the windmills that kill
all the birds
yeah nuclear power is is is great and
essential and we should have more of it
and i believe actually the governor of
tennessee just announced that they were
going to advance uh building a nuclear
plant in tennessee which would be great
if they did so countries like france get
almost 80 percent of their electricity
from nuclear power and they don't seem
to be very afraid of it but yet here in
america we have this notion that it's
this this very scary technology that we
have to run from so no i i love nuclear
and i embrace nuclear but to build a
nuclear plant you need an awful lot of
fossil fuels right to build green energy
you need an also awful lot of fossil
fuels wind turbines solar panels so this
notion that we're ever going to get rid
of fossil fuels is is just a false one
um
the way our economy works the way our
our goods are are produced right now and
manufactured and transported
all requires fossil fuels now maybe in
the future we'll develop some technology
that will get us all fossil fuels but
it's not even close to a reality and
electric vehicles the biden
administration is all up in arms about
electric vehicles and the post office
electric vehicles that they have to all
run on an electric vehicle electric
vehicles are all fossil fuels and not
only that the minerals that are and the
rare earths needed for electric vehicles
to run
are all mined with slave labor in the
congo right so it's that great thomas
soul quote there are no solutions there
are just trade-offs if you say we're
going to get rid of combustion engines
for electric vehicles great there's no
more gas being burned but there's thirty
thousand congolese children working in a
chinese-owned slave mine is is that the
trade-off you want let's just be honest
with the american people and say it's
one of the other guys this third choice
doesn't exist yet it's one or the other
i would choose american jobs over
enslaving more children in the congo but
when you're looking at that time horizon
what what do you say to the people who
are warning that eventually all this
dinosaur juice is going to run up and
then we're going to be left high and dry
yeah i mean we've been predicting a peak
oil jimmy carter talked about peak oil
in the 76 uh the presidential debates by
the year 2000 and i say fossil fuels
because it's a conventional term of
course i know it's not dinosaur bones
oil and gas seem to be replenishing
faster than we ever thought possible and
and the more we look for it the more we
seem to find i look at that as a
blessing from god almighty that has
given us this amazing resource that that
that has made us wealthier healthier i
mean henry viii would long for the life
of comfort that the american average
poor person has right i mean just the
the goods the quality the medicine the
air conditioning the
we have an amazing life because of
fossil fuels it's made us a better
people
um the people who are anti-fossil fuels
they're they're ultimately going to
plunge
more and more people into
misery poverty uh uh um
awful third world conditions the poorest
countries
the most dirty the most polluted the
most enslaved are the ones furthest from
a fossil fuel economy and and that's why
i will always advocate for fossil fuels
there's a lot to get to but first march
2nd is ash wednesday and over a billion
people will start living different in
some way
maybe giving up chocolate or alcohol or
whatever for a lot of folks lent is a
time of finding the easiest way to give
something up but at the end of those 40
days did that sacrifice really make a
difference this year there's a new
opportunity out there specifically for
men that will actually help you grow
closer to god and become a better man
you might have heard me talk about
exodus 90 but let me tell you about
exodus lent a 40-day journey that will
challenge you to dig a little deeper
this year here's how it works first over
the 40 days of lent men commit to daily
prayer setting aside a minimum of 20
minutes to spend with the lord each day
includes a scripture reading and
reflection written to help men better
understand to grow in and live virtue
second more than just giving up
chocolate men take up a range of
disciplines and sacrifices for the
season of lent sweets snacks social
media all gone third men commit to a
fraternity of five to seven men each
week the fraternity meets to pray
together check in hold each other
accountable and encourage one another on
easter sunday you'll walk away with a
new and wonderful understanding of what
it means to live the full christian life
chocolate bunnies and all sign up at
exodus 90.com
michael what's your take on the
political situation because for many
years you had the libs hated fossil
fuels and they were trying to get rid of
them and the conservatives sort of
reflexively defended the fossil fuels do
you think that remains the case or do
you think there's something shifting
perhaps the populist right or or other
other factions of the new right that are
coming up are they more more skeptical
of fossil fuels no i think fossil fuels
as a philosophy or a concept i think
it's right up there with guns
masks right they're just
large phrases that are emblematic of a
much larger cause and so to say i'm
against fossil fuels it's it's like
carrying your your green activist
liberal card someone like bernie sanders
right says he hates fossil fuels his
four homes i'd love to know how they're
powered right his glorious state of
vermont which he says you know we don't
mind for we don't have any fossil fuels
in vermont but they buy electricity from
quebec right across the border which
burns on coal so canadians will gladly
sell the state of vermont electricity at
a premium they're making money off of
the dumb vermonters no offense to the
people of vermont but these are dumb
policies so congrats you pat yourself on
the back and say we don't have fossil
fuels in vermont
no you're just paying the canadians for
their fossil fuels so again
people who hate fossil fuels it's just
this idea of
celebrating liberalism and heck the
biggest fossil fuel uh detractors
dicaprio and as soon as you turn around
they're on a 400 foot mega yacht they're
flying private jets john kerry is never
going to give up his private jets he
hates fossil fuels until he has the jet
to catch him to go windsurfing or win a
snow boarding his snowboard is made of
fossil fuels his suit is made of fossil
fuels they're all just so ignorant it it
hurts me to have to deal with these
people there there does seem to be a
real passing the buck here because you
know dicaprio
john kerry john kerry who to your point
has actually said explicitly i will not
give up my private jet i need to get
places fast and i'm doing so much good
for the world that it doesn't matter if
i don't practice what i preach this is
what leonardo dicaprio is saying too and
then at the the national level
i suppose you're seeing the same thing
yeah we're gonna buy all this oil from
saudi arabia or other places in the
middle east yeah we're going to get
electricity from canada but at least
it's not us doing it i'm just paying the
money but my hands are clean
yeah and then and then the uh the
extension of that equation is by buying
oil and gas from russia
what is vladimir putin doing with his
surplus wealth right why didn't vladimir
putin attack the ukraine for the last uh
four years and there's a twofold reason
when you get into foreign policy one i
believe he truly saw president trump as
an unpredictable but fairly strong
leader and two he didn't have the money
right but now that oil is close to 90 a
barrel and 40 of the russian economy is
fossil fuel sales well vladimir putin is
flush with cash and what are people like
vladimir putin do when they're flush
with cash they don't build schools for
women right they don't empower
minorities and give rights to gays and
lesbians they build armies and they
invade countries
iran has had many small attacks or ran
back militant groups on the uae in the
last couple weeks barely made any news
why is iran suddenly engaging in more
terrorism they have the money they're
flush with cash so so energy
independence in america building
america's energy and fossil fuel economy
doesn't just lower prices for the
average american family it also
depletes the coffers of some of the
world's worst actors and that's that's
really good isn't it wasn't it better
when they had less money um and so again
biden's philosophy biden's farm energy
policy is is is dictating his foreign
policy and putin and and ayatollah
couldn't have come up with a better
policy if they wrote it themselves now
do you think looking at 2022 and 2024
do you think that energy will be a top
issue or just kind of sitting in the
background i remember in elections past
energy was basically the issue or
certainly top three where do you think
it stands right now well i think it's
it's driving our inflation and it's
driving the cost of all goods it's
definitely going to lead in the
elections right the economy is is is
what
is on the top of everyone's mind and
everyone paying a bill every family
every mom driving their kid to school is
suffering uh the price point the problem
though is that energy policies are not
dictated by congress and so even if the
republicans got the house in the senate
deb holland is still not going to allow
permitting on federal land she's still
going to push down these fracking
mandates jennifer granholm the secretary
of energy when she's not laughing on
camera notice she hasn't been on camera
in a long time ever since she laughed
off the fact that that her policies were
making energy expensive right she's
still going to push her electric
vehicles mandates etc so yes energy will
drive a lot of the election cycle but
until there's a replacement in the white
house energy policy is going to stay as
lousy as it is and that's bad for
america's economy and america's uh
families as well that's a great point
that that probably in the way that the
government ought to work congress would
have much more of a say here but that's
just not the way that it happens a lot
of these policies are coming right out
of the executive branch often they're
coming out of the administrative
agencies sometimes there's there's
virtually no electoral oversight on that
at all so all the more important for
people to make their voices heard uh not
just at the ballot box in november but
but beyond that and especially looking
into 2024 daniel where can people find
you they can i think they can find you
everywhere you're all over tv you're all
over podcasts
and now i'm on your show and i got to
tell you this is a great honor because
i've been a big fan of yours for a long
time so like check the box like
yes powerthefuture.com and thanks for a
really good conversation about this very
important issue well thank you very much
i appreciate your coming on because
there's so there's so much
misinformation out there on these issues
and there's so so many straw man
arguments on the left and you are you
are a pyromaniac in a field of these uh
knocking down all of these straw man
arguments from the left which is very
good we can we can use all of our you
know
all we can actually use fossil fuels
when we do that i guess to burn down
these kind of silly arguments about
uh about even just the way the economy
is working now because uh uh to your
point i think it's maybe the most astute
point you made
they're not offering an alternative
they're not really offering much of an
alternative at all they're just offering
much less efficient ways ways that are
going to harm the american uh energy
consumer and the american taxpayers so
thank you daniel appreciate you coming
on and thank you we'll see you next time
hope so thanks
[Music]
[Music]